welcome to c 0 plane ready yeah not
Richard ready Johan echevarria from
Columbia that's nice so probably some
kind of yeah let's do this setup it's
something that I had looked at some
years ago not bad as you can see I can
play the moves pretty quickly sometimes
it helps to having studied stuff okay I
think I'm taking this pawn right what is
your point probably there's no point but
line is I'm taking this sorry this gave
me first of all and then I rook on a two
that's funny okay what a funny game okay
you enter he played the d3 year we not
not bad I mean it's just some somewhat
modest start but it's been played often
enough bye bye top players this is the
setup with the Knights their own b6 and
sis it's not bad because I get a good
simple development here and I'm ready
for that deform and victor in fact I
believe that d for right here is not so
well time I think why should try to
prepare that better with Bishop e3 your
moves like that
yeah i think i'm pretty comfortable
white can try you by the way to not take
and play things like 90 to 1 or this is
also a possibility here um i already
like my position you just have to be
aware of your 5 of course or g6 and this
is a position that back then I i looked
at and felt that black is in very good
shape because the business bishops are
strong and the night has a good square
and c4 and in general if you look at
this though this to pawn say under fire
and it's not so easy to develop and he
went Ruby one allowing yeah preparing be
three but whoops first porn and just
went back went here here and then he had
forgotten about it again bush that was
funny ok I hope you enjoyed the game as
much as I did thanks for watching